[Music]
I'm voting for Hillary because I'm a
feminist and he's a psychopath
I believe that Donald Trump will lower
our taxes repeal Obamacare and just make
America great again I'm voting for
Hillary because in my opinion she's the
most qualified candidate for the job
Hillary and Donald are both very biased
Harry Johnson is a more honest candidate
I'm super-pumped 'vote for Hillary we're
a woman of color she definitely is
talking about things that are important
to me
Trump is not a career politician I
believe he's in genuine when he wants to
put America first and I believe that
Hillary speaks for herself when she
first started running she wasn't my
first choice but then we had this guy
come along and like it's just so
unacceptable it's not even a choice
Hillary Clinton is a war monger she's
got blood on her hands and that's why
I'm voting for Trump I believe in that
good the most good for the most amount
of people and I think Hillary is clearly
the candidate who will accomplish that
honestly I don't like Donald Trump I
love him and I think he's a great man
and I think he's gonna do great things
when he becomes president I support
Hillary because first of all let
everyone don't know what he's talking
about I'm afraid of what he'll do he
will enforce federal laws and he will
get rid of Obamacare and he will build a
wall to secure our borders I feel really
uncomfortable sitting like I'm with her
because so much of why I stand with
Hillary is because I'm in such
opposition to Trump which i think is a
frail and faulty system with a two-party
system you're more likely to get whoever
is the wealthiest or more endorsed by
wealthy people
as opposed to who might be the most
educated or excellent vote for Hillary
because she's the candidate with the
biggest balls
[Music]